simon abadi was wearing a backpack that
was so heavy
that it bent him over within it
was a bomb packed with shrapnel
who convinced this young man to put a 32
kilogram bomb
in his backpack there is evidence that
he could have been stopped
the man in the yellow jacket is a member
of security staff at the arena
who was told that salman abadi was
acting suspiciously before the explosion
the man who told him witness a actually
confronted salman abadi
witness a says that he asked the man
what have you got in your rucksack
but got no response witness a then
said it doesn't look very good you know
what you see with bombs and such
you with a rucksack like this in a place
like this
what are you doing the man responded
i'm waiting for somebody mate have you
got the time
the security guard flagged a baby to a
colleague
the second security guard then tried to
alert the control room but all of his
radio channels were busy
and he watched as salman abadi carried
his backpack
closer towards the arena itself i just
froze the security guard said
and didn't get anything out on the radio
i knew at that point
it was too late the 22 victims were
remembered
on this the first day of the inquiry
kelly brewster
georgina calendar
olivia campbell hardy
[Music]
olivia was 15 years old
he was flagged and there wasn't much
done hurts a bit
but knowing that he was seen
is a bit of a relief really because that
there's others
that need to know that you know it can
be learned from
it's only three weeks since hashem abadi
the brother who helped make the bomb
was jailed for life with a minimum of 55
years
the inquiry will also examine
significant concerns
that police commanders took too long to
allow
ambulance and fire crews in to help it
meant people like shaun gardner
were left on their own trying to save
people's lives
it's obviously left some really deep
scars and there was always going to be a
five or ten minute gap but
you know it was 20 25 minutes by the
time
we were we actually got some assistance
what counter-terrorism officers knew
will be too sensitive to be heard in
public but the inquiry chairman
has vowed to be as open as he can be the
process he says
isn't about finding scapegoats but
establishing
the truth tom parmenter sky news
manchester